when i put on twitter that i was going
to talk to you
uh one i got a million tweets of people
talking about star wars and asking him
about star wars
are you a little surprised at the fans
still wanting you to return to play
qui-gon in some way
i i'll be honest with you i haven't
heard that at all
oh i i've definitely heard it okay
um sure i'd like to i mean i'm
wondering if star wars starting to fade
away from the
cinema landscape do we think actually
disney plus is launching like 10 series
that are based on star wars and one of
them is
an obi-wan series with ewan mcgregor
okay
they're sort of spin-offs are they yeah
it's gonna it's gonna take place
see i was wondering if ewing had called
you and said um
hey i'm doing a spin-off series maybe we
can do like a flashback
sure i'd be up for that yeah i hope you
get to return
i loved your work in star wars and i
love your work and everything thank you
so much for your time
thank you mike i appreciate it thank you